[Music]
what
well hello dear friends thank you so
much for joining us for our program I'd
like to know uh this is a question and
answer program where you who watch them
send us your questions we do research
and then uh based on the research that
we do we do our best to try and answer
your questions let me give you the
electronic address where you can send
the questions to us you'll see it on the
screen
TVM tv.org
once again
TVM tv.org we would be delighted to
receive your questions do the research
and provide biblical and spiritual
prophecy answers uh we also want to
encourage you to continue praying for
our ministry we produce many many
programs and we also appreciate your
financial support of Secrets unsealed in
some TV which makes it possible for us
to continue broadcasting quality
programs I have with me Pastor David
Salasar a good friend of the ministry
he's in charge of the Spanish Outreach
of su TV uh I guess uh your official
title is COO of Hispanic um uh social
media and some TV we're glad to have you
with us along with your family and uh
thank you for joining the program today
thank you Pastor for inviting me to be
here with you and it's a blessing and a
privilege for for me to work with you
and share this time together as well
praise the lord well we have some very
good questions today like we usually do
and uh we want to begin with a word of
prayer never should we open the word
without prayer amen so would you pray
for us please absolutely heavenly father
as we come before you we are so thankful
that you allow us to uh tap into your
word to understand and to answer the
questions that come our way we ourselves
are not uh of any knowledge and we don't
have any virt in ourselves but we know
that through your grace and the power of
the Holy Spirit we can be uh led to all
truth and we can be taught by you so we
pray that uh we can now receive your
holy spirit that the answers May reach
the hearts and bring Clarity and uh
answer the questions that those that
have sent May provide with the the
answering that they need and we thank
you for your grace we pray this in Jesus
name amen
amen well the first question that we
have comes from Carol and uh she's
actually writing from Eastern Cape South
Africa and uh before we get to the
question I want to read her comment
about uh her uh the hours that she's
watching the program and the blessing
that it's been I write from South Africa
I found your program on YouTube and am
fast catching up on all of them the past
week I even watched a live program 10 pm
Tuesday night
thank you you are my friends without
knowing it widowed in 2021 and living in
a remote very small village 120
kilometers from my nearest church with
the high cost of fuels programs like
yours become a real heartwarming
blessing praise the Lord you know this
is music to our ears amen uh one of the
reasons why we have this ministry is
because through social media and media
in general we're were able to reach
people who are not able to go to church
uh during the pandemic it was a huge
blessing because people couldn't go to
church absolutely and yet we were
broadcasting all during the pandemic uh
both Sabbath school and worship service
as well as other programming so uh this
is music to our ears to know that we're
making a difference uh where people live
absolutely uh then comes the question uh
I was wondering while listening to uh
this is a lecture that I did during an
anchor school from the close of
probation to the new Earth mhm I accept
that the sealed ones will go through the
time of trouble the last plagues and the
Lord will
protect however I don't understand why
the trauma and Agony for the end time
living ones as the plagues after the
close of probation are meant to punish
the disobedient lost ones do you
understand why or is it just because the
Lord Wills it so so what is the reason
why the living Saints at the end of time
are going to have to go through this
severe time of trouble during the period
of the plagues uh how do we explain that
why doesn't God just uh second coming
and he resurrects uh righteous dead and
the living Saints um you know take both
groups to Heaven why this time of
trouble that's a good question pastor
and I believe our friend Carol is is
really has a good point especially when
we hear from a lot
of people who are
preaching good messages or or not good
messages but messages that sound good
but are not necessarily found in the
Bible you know specifically speaking of
The Last Day Events you know there is a
lot of confusion as to what really
happens evangelicals preach an idea that
you know God's going to take people
Rapture right away with before seeing
anything going on and uh uh and then the
rest of the people are going to be
somehow in some trial here for seven
years and you know be able to finally
also be delivered um but in adventism we
of course don't believe that that's not
biblical but in adventism there's been
this push to a certain degree of a
similar idea somewhat thinking that you
know God is going to save camp for his
people and we just need to is love the
Lord and really not you know worry so
much about know judgment or or about you
know the sealing of or or finishing of
the D of provation basically given the
idea in the minds of people that you
know the guy doesn't need to um close
probation to go through a time of travel
to go through this trial because at the
end of the day God will save his people
and there's no need for that but if we
really go to the word of God we clearly
understand there is a reason there is a
reason why people the elect are going to
have to go to to this time of trouble
well Matthew 24 uh Jesus speaks in
verses uh 21 and 22 that there shall be
a Great Tribulation such as was not
since the beginning of the world to this
time nor nor ever shall be and except
those days should be shortened there
should be no flesh be saved but for the
elect's sake those days shall be
shortened so I believe and this is
telling us there will be a time of
trouble there will not be time of
probation a time of uh extreme
tribulation and that time God will
intervene in behalf of his people to
save them and it's because of them that
you know the time of trouble becomes or
the time of tribulation becomes uh in a
sense bearable because God will shorten
the day so God will do a part A
miraculous part in in providing a way to
save them but they still have to go to
travel time of travel so the question is
why do we have they have to go go why do
they have to go well the reason and and
you probably will add more to of course
what to this but we if we go to the book
of uh great controversy chapter 39 and I
believe and I would suggest to Carol
that she can read this whole chapter you
know I studied for herself but Spirit
prophecy speaks to us the following and
this is important it says when the third
Angel's message closes mercy no longer
pleads for the guilty inhabitants of the
Earth the people of God have
accomplished their work they have
received the latter rain the refreshing
from the presence of the Lord and they
are prepared for the trying hour before
them so there's a trying hour this is
the timee of tribulation this is the
trying hour angels are hastening to and
from Heaven an angel returning from the
earth announces that his work is done
the final test has been brought upon the
world and all who have proved themselves
loyal to the Divine precepts have
received the Seal of of the Living God
then Jesus ceases his intercession in
the sanctuary above he lifts his hands
and with a loud voice says it is done
and all the Angelic hosts lay off their
crowns as he makes the solemn
announcement he that is unjust let him
be unjust still and he which is filthy
let him be filthy still and he that is
righteous let him be righteous still and
he that is Holy let him be holy still
every case has been decided for life and
or death
Christ has made atonement for his people
and blooded out their sins so here we
see that this is where God stops
interceding Jesus stops interceding for
us now comes this last moment of test of
trial and this is where he spes the next
paragraph says when he leaves the
sanctuary Darkness covers the
inhabitants of the Earth in that fearful
time the righteous must live in the
sight of a holy God without an
intercessor
the restraints which has been been upon
the wicked is removed and Satan has
entire control of the finally impenitent
God's longsuffering has ended the world
has rejected his Mercy despise his love
and trample upon his law the wicked have
passed the boundary of their provation
the spirit of God persistently resisted
has been at last withdrawn and sheltered
by divine grace they have no protection
from the wicked one Satan will then
plunge the inhabitants of the earth into
one great final trouble as the angels of
God cease to hold in check the fierce
Winds of human passion all the elements
of strife will be let loose the whole
world will be involved in a ruin more
terrible than that which Came Upon
Jerusalem of old and as and then just
the last part want I read is this those
who have honored the law of God have
been accused of bringing judgments upon
the world and they will be regarded as
the cause of the fearful compulsions of
Nature and the strife and bloodshed
among men that are filling the Earth
with woe
so why would that happen God sees an
intercession no longer there is a time
of of of
provation God's people have to the
faithful ones have to stand before a
holy guy without intercession they have
to live a life that is in harmony with
his precepts and Satan is controlling
the masses controlling the
world which will uh you know he used
that to try to destroy the remnant of
his people remnant of God this is the
time where the test of our faith will be
severely tried where our loyalty to God
will be put in you know in in the most
acute trial possible so this is why this
has to happen it is the only way that
God's character can be medicated that
the people who have received Christ in
their Hearts can truly stand before the
world being in a perfect obedient to the
law of God and are willing to be
faithful to God even if it would cost
them their lives so it's is a is a
moment of trial Pastor you can
absolutely add more to this yeah you
know the bottom line is that the plagues
are not for God's people right the
plagues are for the wicked God's people
will be present mhm but the plagues will
not fall on them yeah uh you know the
psalm 91 is the Great Tribulation Psalm
uh I'll just read a few verses a
thousand may fall at your side and
10,000 at your right hand but it shall
not come near you only with your eyes
shall you look and see the reward of the
wicked because you have made the Lord
who is my refuge even the most high your
dwelling place no evil shall befall you
nor shall any plague come near your
dwelling mhm mhm so uh even though God's
people are going to live during that
time the plagues are not going to
afflict them uh Daniel 12 ver1 also
mentions that time of trouble uh the
where the living Saints will go through
it says at that time Michael shall stand
up which is Jesus uh the great prince
who stands watch over the sons of your
people in other words he's the protector
of his people yeah and there shall be a
time of trouble such as never was since
there was a nation even to that time and
at that time your people shall be
delivered everyone who is found written
in the book now Satan uh says well yeah
Jesus overcame uh totally and completely
sin he lived a life of Victory because
he was God yeah he was he wasn't like
everybody else he was like God but at
the end God is going to have an entire
generation of saints mhm who are going
to be faithful to God under the word
circumstances and they're going to say
though he slay me yeah yet will I trust
in him Amen in other words they are
going to be an exhibit before the
universe that these people serve God
only out of love yes and not
self-interest you know the best
illustration that I've been able to find
of this is in the story of
Job why did God allow job to go through
all of his Affliction it was a terrible
Affliction and he was a righteous man
mhm you read chapter one and chapter 2
God himself said you know he's uh he
asses evil he rejects evil you know
perfect and and so on and uh so why did
God allow Satan to do this to him
because God wanted to demonstrate before
the Heavenly beings a very important
quality about about job and that is that
he was faithful to God not because of
the Loaves and the fishes not only in
the good times yeah but he was faithful
to God because he loved God M he wasn't
a mercenary yeah in other words God is
going to have an entire last generation
and I know that this in in many circles
in the Adventist Church is disliked yes
the idea that during the time of trouble
God's people are going to live a life
without sinning right uh because there's
no intercessor for the sins at that time
God is going to have an entire
generation of saints right who are going
to be faithful to God under the worst
circumstances and so God is going to say
to the devil not what was your
argument there is no argument anymore
because these are human beings with
sinful natures and yet they're gaining
the victory over sin the way that Jesus
gained the victory uh not over sin
because Jesus never sinned but the
victory over every Temptation that came
to him and so uh this is the reason why
God is going to allow the Saints to go
through this time of trouble was is as a
demonstration to the universe and by the
way uh I have an entire sermon on the
Book of Job where I develop this theme
but when you really look at chapter 1
and two job lost every earth support
everything he lost his
children he lost his servants he lost
his possessions he lost his health he
lost the support of his wife he lost the
support of his friends the Nations Rose
against him and spit in his face he says
and it appeared like he had lost God
because from chapter 3 to chapter 38
he's crying out to God and God's answer
is
silence and yet he has no earthly
support it appears that there is no
Heavenly support and yet he says though
he slay me yet will I trust in him he
said I know my redeemer lives even
though I can't feel him I can't see him
I know he lives that's going to be the
characteristic of the final generation
the final Victorious
generation go God does not make them go
through this time because God is a
masochist yeah and and I say I say that
not irreverently because oh he enjoys
seeing his people suffer no it's because
he wants to demonstrate before the
universe that he has a totally loyal
people who keep the Commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus that's the real
reason why they go through a time of
trouble if I could just read here a
statement from great controversy 621
mhm Ellen White explains why he's why
God is going to allow his people to go
through this time the assaults of Satan
are Fierce and
determined his delusions are terrible
but the Lord's eye is upon his people
and his hear listens ear listens to
their cries their Affliction is great
the Flames of the Furnace seem about to
consume them but the refiner will bring
them forth as gold tried in the fire mhm
God's love for his children During the
period of their severest trial is as
strong and tender as in the days of
their sunniest Prosperity but it is
needful for them to be placed in the
furnace of fire their earthliness must
be consumed that the image of Christ may
be perfectly
reflected amen so what did she mean when
she says their earthliness must be
consumed uh she did not use the word
worldliness because they're not going to
be
worldly earthliness means everything
that attaches them to this earth they're
willing to lose everything that they
have on this Earth to be faithful to God
and in the process they will come forth
from the furnace as pure gold no draws
whatsoever no attachment to this world
they're going to go have the same
experience as Enoch MH you know Enoch
developed a character so so similar to
the character of Christ that eventually
Christ said Enoch you have no reason to
live on earth anymore you know your body
is on Earth but your mind is in heaven
come let's walk down the street of the
New Jerusalem and so that is what God is
waiting for when the character of Christ
is perfectly reproduced in his people
then he will come to claim them as his
own Christ object lessons page 69 amen
amen there is the reason you know that
even if in our lives now the Lord allows
our trials our experiences to go through
certain tribulation or refinement
because as Hebrews 1210 mentions that
the trials unlike the trials that are
parents or the punishment if you will
the word punishment uses by by your
parents has done for us to help us not
to be bad or you know to behave well in
the same man the trials that God allows
in our lives is so that we can part
partake of his Holiness to partake of
that experience of being Sanctified
refined become pure Holier so as you
mentioned Pastor it is absolutely right
reason why the Lord wants us to or
allows us to go through that experience
but with the Lord's help we will be
Overcomers and uh I think that you know
we got to give glory to him for that
amen well you know the next person has
sent several
questions uh the person is Sebert
and uh there is no location where he is
writing
from um and we don't have time probably
to answer all of the questions but uh
let's uh let's give it a whirl yeah uh
when does one's name get his or her name
written in the Book of Life we were
having a Bible study and two people said
one's name is written from
birth so the question is when is our
name written in the Book of Life
well uh the Apostle Peter speaks in uh
in you know in the book of um in his
sermon in the book of Acts to those that
were um and I'll go to the book of Acts
I believe is
chapter
four
um let me see
here um oh chapter three I'm sorry
verse
19 he's speaking there and says uh
repent ye therefore and be converted
that your sins may be blotted out when
the times of the refresh shall come from
the presence of the Lord and you know he
is speaking to them
that their names right that their sins
their sins may be blooded out if they
when they repent and be converted so
when there is a conversion experience
when there is a a coming to Christ the
sins can be forgiven erased it is the
moment that your name is written in the
Book of Life when you are converted
usually that comes with baptism you know
and and he speaks of calling to baptism
so when you are baptized you becoming a
new person there's a new birth in that
moment of New
Birth your your name is written in the
book of Heaven that is the moment it is
written um
now can it be removed from the book of
life it can you know if you decide to go
back to your life and you de have to
move away from God and you reject the
lord well that name can be eventually
raised if that's the case you know if
you have you will depart from the faith
but when you get converted when you
become baptized when you have that new
ver experience that's why you are
written in the Book of Life That's the
moment you get written in the Book of
Life yeah uh yes and the spirit of
Prophecy makes it clear that a person's
name is written in the Book of Life at
the moment of their baptism but there's
more to the story you see there's God's
perspective MH of when our name is
written and then there's our perspective
yes you know God lives in an eternal
present we can't really understand that
that's be um Ellen White has a statement
where she says the past the present and
the fut are alike to God M I mean uh God
doesn't uh doesn't consider time in
segments like we do yeah you know he
doesn't look at the past and then he
looks at the present and then you know
he imagines what the future is going to
be like he lives in an eternal present
which means that he looks at things as
if they're transpiring before his eyes
at the very moment right and and so um
from God's perspective the names are
written in the Book of
Life from the beginning of time actually
ever not even from the beginning of time
forever yeah forever because God lives
in an eternal presence right right so so
the names of the saved have been written
The Book of Life from God's perspective
from eternity past right um and uh from
our perspective the moment when they're
actually written in the book is when
we're baptized but God already
knew from eternity past that a name was
going to be written in the book because
we receive Christ as our savior so um
the bottom line is that my name is
written in the book of life because God
already knew beforehand the choice that
I was going to
make but when I make the choice that's
actually the moment from my perspective
when my name is written in the book of
life right uh so we always have to
consider God's perspective and our
perspective you know we have a Bible
verse on this uh Revelation chapter 17
and verse 8 tells us that the names of
the Lost were not written in The Book of
Life from the foundation of the world
now if the if the names of the Lost are
not written in the Book of Life from the
foundation of the world then the names
of those who are saved were written in
the Book of Life from the foundation of
the world it says there in verse eight
the Beast that you saw was and is not
and will Ascend out of the bottomless
pit and go to
predition and those who dwell on the
earth will this is future still will
Marvel whose names are not written in
the Book of Life from the the foundation
of the world yeah so that's God's
perspective they were not written in the
Book of Life from the foundation of the
world because God already knew what
their choice was going to be in
rejecting uh God and following the Beast
uh so we need to keep in mind that there
are two perspectives God's perspective
because he knows everything he knows
who's going to be in the book who isn't
going to be in the book but he but from
our perspective at a certain historical
moment is when it actually happens right
right thank you that's very clear Pastor
you're right uh and that's the thing you
know he he wants us to understand I
guess if we want to make it this way his
perspective is different than ours we
need to act upon what we know and make
the decision for Christ so that we can
have a new bir experience have that
opportunity to be in the Book of Life
and remain there by the grace of God
yeah and uh he who perseveres to the end
will be saved amen he who endures till
the end is the king James version says
we'll be saved uh so uh you know God
wants everyone to be saved he would like
everybody's name to be in the book of
life but it all depends on our choice uh
you know we're we're not Calvinists yes
where you believe that God said well you
know these individuals I like them
they're going to be written in the Book
of Life from eternity past and this
other group tough tough luck I choose
for you to be lost it's not the choice
of God right God knows what our choice
is and based on his for knowledge he
already knows who's going to be in the
Book of Life and who isn't absolutely
from our perspective the moment when we
make the choice that's when it's
actually written what God already
foresaw in eternity P amen and that's
why the choices or choices important I
mean we got to make that decision daily
Pastor to remain there with him that's
right remain rooted in Christ and uh
keep our names in the book of life so
the Book of Life uh eventually will
reveal that we have accepted Christ as
our savior well uh you know time flies
by when we're having a good time
absolutely but uh our time is just about
up I want to thank you all for sending
your questions you'll see on the screen
where you can send them TVM tv.org
TVM tv.org we'd be glad to receive your
questions thank you so much for joining
us God bless you all and we hope hope to
see you at our next program I'd like to
know
[Music]
blessing